this is just a little bit of what you
missed from jocko underground if you
want to hear the rest of the
conversation and more go to
jacounderground.com
um how do you adapt jiu jitsu when
outnumbered and in something more
serious than a playground or bar fight
yeah um
so outnumbered what are you gonna do
well first of all we avoid getting in
fights where we're outnumbered and you
avoid it at all freaking costs
because the chances of you winning a
fight while you're outnumbered is very
small now availability bias will tell
you if you watch youtube of boxer knocks
out three people or whatever you can
think you're gonna pull that off
you're not
you are not you can you have
a one percent chance of doing that
even if you're freaking skilled
you know can you come up against three
guys or four guys that are drunk or
stupid or untrained
yes you can um actually i saw i saw a
meme
i saw a meme and it said
how i think i'm going to win a street
fight and it was like a pie chart yeah
and there was a little tiny sliver that
was like three percent of the pine that
said you know i train
on a regular basis and the other giant
part of the pie was something
something along the lines of
quote you don't know me bro when i see
red i get wild and i'm gonna get nuts
and
no one's gonna be able to hold me back
or something like that which is which is
still the truth even even in today's
world of mma and all that stuff yeah
because you got to remember now
everybody knows a little bit of mma
so it's not like now if you're a guy
that watches ufc and you think you know
a little bit from watching ufc and
you're going to get nuts and that's how
you're going to win well everyone else
knows a little bit of ufc too everybody
so that get nuts thing
first of all it was never
real
but now just because you're going to get
nuts and you have a little bit of ufc
watching on tv like it's not going to
work out so okay so so we are going to
avoid getting in strikes with a bunch of
people getting in fights with a bunch of
people if we can't avoid it yes
jiu-jitsu is not your first option
like hey i'm gonna grab this guy and and
start to grapple with this guy while
three other guys are hitting me in the
head with beer bottles or or with you
know because he's talking about
something more serious than a playground
or a bar fight
whatever they're going to hit you with
or stab you
right
you're going to you're going to
not want to engage you want to hit
people and get away you still want to
get away your goal is still to get away
and then
the next thing he is it's something like
a time for dirty judo or or the sykes
fair burn which is
this is stuff
that they taunt world war ii the
commandos taught it
and
it's just basically big gross motor
movements
to
disable your opponent as quickly as
possible
and
theoretically
it's
it's like okay that's a good theoretical
thing to think about yeah
realistically it's not as
it's it's it's it's a good theory that's
gonna work sometimes and it's also not
going to work a bunch of the time so
you know um for instance
a groin strike
a groin strike that's something that'll
come you know you knee to the groin or a
shin kick to the groin
that's great
can it be
you know a shock if you're in a fight
with somebody and and you nail them
sure
but guess what it's not going to end the
fight
it's real it's actually not going to end
very well let me rephrase that there's a
one percent chance that it ends the
fight what if you go for an eye gouge
because that's like super hostile right
it seems like oh well once i gouge their
eyes i win the fight it's not true i've
had people try to gouge my eyes before
and it is not an effective method for
stopping someone i did not stop
so
even though those things sound like well
i'll just do this or i'll remember we uh
had a guy at victory
got into a street fight and the dude got
crazy and bit his ear off or bit a big
chunk out of his ear
and
even though the guy our fighter
lost part of his ear he still won the
fight and could have killed the other
person had he wanted to so even biting
off someone's ear or what you think is
going to be this big shocking thing it's
not it doesn't stop small joint
manipulation this is an interesting one
if i break your fingers like if we are
in a if you and i are if you and i are
training
and i grab one of your fingers and break
it you're going to be like bro we're
going to stop right because i just broke
your finger yeah if i'm trying to kill
you and i break your finger you don't
give a [ __ ]
you're going to keep coming
if i fish hook you
right if i fish hook you
and we're training well you're going to
move your head and you're going to kind
of comply with my fishhook
if we're
fighting to the death you're going to
bite my finger off
um
here's another one
if
you decide you're going to
grab my
hair which i don't have any for obvious
reasons if someone grabs your hair like
that's that's a legit thing where they
get control over you so you got to be
careful that when we don't really grab
hair a lot in training
so would you grab hair in a fight yeah
that's a really good takedown too like
if you if you've ever grabbed someone by
the hair and shocked their balance you
can really take someone down quite
easily just by grabbing their hair
unless they're a good wrestler and then
all of a sudden you're kind of instilled
you're almost like in a judo fight right
you just happen to use their hair as a
ghee
um
so so the idea
that
hey
here's what it boils down to
if you and i are gonna fight
and now we're fighting to the death
and
you've trained jiu jitsu
and i've not
you are gonna destroy me
and i might scratch your eyes i might i
might scratch near one of your eyes for
a half a second before you arm lock me
or before you choke me or before you get
the mountain and punch me in the head 17
times or elbow me in the face
you might be able to get a little bit of
damage on me
but you're
your attempt to kick me in the groin
your attempt to throat punch me all
those things are going to fall short i'm
going to take or sorry this is when you
train jitsu and i don't if i try and
throat punch you or i try and poke your
eyes or i try and kick you in the groin
all those things there's a .001 chance
that i nail the perfect groin shot or i
actually stick one of my fingers i'm not
going to get both my fingers in your
eyes
i might get one in
and guess what you can still see how the
other one you're going to freaking now
you're going to do a double leg you're
going to take me down you're going to
kill me
so
what's the deal here
train jiu jitsu train boxing train muay
thai train wrestling and then if you
want to start looking at some of the old
school
hey where are some vulnerable areas
that's fine you know what they are
already you
occasionally incorporate some of them
sure you want to if you're training a
female in some level of self-defense
should they be thinking about how they
could do some of these strikes sure but
if you think that a female is gonna
give a guy a kick to the groin followed
by an uh what do they call that like a
palm strike to the face and that's gonna
stop a 220 pound guy it is not going to
it is not going to
there's a much better chance that she's
able to
um
sort of
pretend to be weak
and allow the dude to get into a certain
position before she springs a freaking
triangle choke or uh or uh you know
escapes to the back and gets a rear
naked or something like that
way
infinitely better chance
if you think that you're gonna if you
think you're gonna incapacitate somebody
with one strike and that's what you're
counting on you're wrong
can it happen yes
is it going to happen
not likely
train jiu jitsu train muay thai train
boxing train wrestling if you want to
take a look at some old school
uh hyper aggressive gross motor skills
to incapacitate people sure look at them
but you cannot rely on it
you know what you can rely on if you're
hyper aggressive with one of those and
someone's not expecting it sure it'll
work
you know like someone comes up and gets
in your face and you've just freaking
you know you strike first fast and hard
you can get the upper hand
you can definitely get the upper hand
if they're ready to fight then none of
that [ __ ] works yeah yeah if they're
ready to fight that's a big one up
yeah i think sometimes
jiu-jitsu gets like almost like this
unfair
thing where it's almost like a straw man
argument where and they'll do funny
videos about it where it's like oh yeah
did you tune a street fight then the guy
will be like hey you want to go you want
to go and the guy will like pull guard
or something like that yeah
and yeah that's not you don't that's not
how you employed you just doing a in a
real life scenario jiu-jitsu this is
what i wrote about in disciplinary field
manual
you learn to grapple
because if you if you echo charles
we're in the street and you want to
fight me and you square up to me i'm
gonna run away
if you try and kick me you don't have
control of me i'm gonna run away if you
try and punch me you don't have control
of me i'm gonna run away
if you if you square off and push me
cool you just push me away i'm running
away so if i'm to get i'm not going to
get you i don't need to fight i can get
away from you and i don't want to fight
because i don't know where your friends
are if you have a blade in your back
pocket or if you have a pistol with you
i don't want to get arrested i don't
want to get sued all these things so my
goal is to not fight so if you try and
push me kick me strike me i'm going to
get away from you
the minute you grab me
i don't have that option anymore i need
to earn that option
i need to
grapple i need to counter your grappling
to get away from you hopefully i can do
it while you're while we're standing
hopefully my
wrestling and my standing jiu jitsu and
my judo is enough for me to break
whatever grip you have
and get away from you that's what my
goal is and then i get away from you
if i can't do that
and you get control of me now i need to
work even harder now you get me to the
ground
what good are my strikes on the ground
they're not any good at all
i need to know jujitsu i need to know
how to get up and get away from you
that's what jiu jitsu is for in the
street so
train as much as you can
keep an open mind
and avoid getting in situations like
this because if you're outnumbered
the
again the 99.9
chances you're about to get
beat down yeah outnumbered
best thing is to leave for sure